[Music]
first of all congratulations just hours
ago you win a Golden Globe how do you
feel I went out last night afterwards
you went out who did you go out with
Quentin Quentin Tarantino I can only
imagine what it's like to go out to
celebrate with Quentin Tarantino no you
pimped if you're right I can't
where did you go you can't even you have
to tell me where you went but I guess
you were out very late I'm not sure I
could yeah you don't know where you were
last night I followed I kind of followed
the lead yeah yeah it was good it wasn't
fun this morning but right you have no
idea where you are right now do you
yeah I have to say congratulations you
got the Golden Glove last night and then
you are of course nominated at the
Oscars again this has just got to be an
amazing feeling for you
it it is completely overwhelming um I
usually when I'm asked this question
that's it can you see right you start
moving your mouth but nothing comes out
terrible for a talk show can I
compliment you I loved your performance
Andy and I were talking about Django
Unchained today and we loved your
performance and I also I have to say I
was a huge fan of your beard in that
film you had the most amazing beard in
Django Unchained I think looks great
thank you it there it is right there
that's I can't get a beard like that
lots of mustache twirling - yeah well
yeah no no it I treated it like my pet
and and I was sorry to see it go um it
felt like a Schwinn sheep in a way
underneath you got used to it and you it
did feel like it was a part of you you
said it really it felt like a pat to you
a little bit you know you gave it its
shots you threw the bat yeah
but I went through a period where I had
a beard and then I took it off and I
felt I did feel naked for a while
absolutely yeah and then I went on to
another movie and I shaved my head and
my eyebrows and that was naked yeah why
the eyebrows I understand shaving your
head but shaving your eyebrows just
seems like this is a fraternity prank so
this isn't a movie at all no no I've did
so I hope it's gonna be a great movie
and yeah but that feels strange
I can imagine I'm not doing that I'm not
calling you on that one is it true I
heard a rumor that on the set of Django
Quentin Tarantino would have that you
guys would do shots in between takes at
certain points is that true yes and no
look that means yes when someone says
yes and no to a question like that
it means more yes than no but when
Quentin shoots a thousand yards of film
then you know there's a little
celebration and just to mark it you know
I think it's a thousand yards no it must
be more anyway well whatever there's a
certain amount a round numbered one
right all right I remember thousand
yards would come up pretty ah yeah yeah
yeah exactly
I think it is a thousand yards
I think you're doing a shot every six
minutes thank you working no it was work
I mean you know come on in all
seriousness yeah please also very
serious Quentin notoriously very serious
and strict about cell phones on the set
yeah which I think would be very
important but absolutely excuse me what
would he do what would he do if it's an
important take and someone's cell phone
went off it only happened once in the
two movies that I've worked with him and
it wasn't even a cell phone it was
somebody booting his computer but that
nasty mmm so reminded him also cell
phone and he said I told you no phones
got up left and that was it for the day
he's very strict about cell phones and I
appreciate it enormously because despite
the stories about shots and all that I
have very strict work work ethic yes and
that the constant usage of you know them
texting and talking and and it's it's
really distracting in all seriousness no
I agree with you when we rehearse this
show and yes we do rehearse when we
rehearse this show I'm sorry Andy but
you're on your device constantly and I
find it a distraction spend an afternoon
with you and stay off a device I'm sorry
you had to hear